fallout from tax reform continues nikki
Haley is my spirit animal
at the un+ Hollywood actually did
something right
really I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show okely-dokely so much to get
through you know at the end of the week
it's been a long week and it's only
Thursday I mean it really feels like it
should be Friday at this point so we're
just sitting around the office making
Star Wars jokes at this point I won't
spoil Star Wars further with the joke
that I just made that is spectacular and
then I stole from Ben Domenech over at
the federalists but before we get to
anything of real interest and there's a
lot of news happening first I want to
say thank you to our sponsor is over at
tracker so I lose my keys and I lose my
wallet and I lose my phone a lot my wife
does it even more than I do and I can
say that with a straight face and in all
candor but no longer thanks to tracker
so tracker is the best device to prevent
you from losing your wallet your phone
your keys right the way that it works is
that it's a coin size device you stick
it on your keys and now when you lose
your keys you take your phone you hit a
button and boom your keys are ringing
and you can find them and if you lose
your phone and even if you turned it off
right you turned off the sound on your
phone and so it's silent alright this is
always driven everybody nuts you lose
your phone you try to call the phone it
but it rings but you can't hear it cuz
it's on silent well now when you have
when you have tracker then all you have
to do is hit the button and boom your
phone rings right through it tracker
comm is the best Lightness Bluetooth
tracking device on the market you put
the tracker pixel on whatever you tend
to lose and it is small enough to fit
anywhere you can track your item even if
it's miles away because every tracker
user is also a part of the largest crowd
locate network in the world it's like
Waze except for finding your stuff and
they have a 30-day money-back guarantee
which means that you really don't have
anything to lose it makes a great gift
it is a very useful gift for the holiday
season so during this holiday season
save 20% off your order when you go to
the tracker comm slash appear oh that's
the track our comm slash appear oh you
get 20% off that tracker comm slash
Shapiro you get 20% off use the slash
pen so they know that we sent you as
well and make your life easier and less
frustrating ok so we begin today it will
do taxes in a second you know I want to
begin today instead with the UN so the
UN right now as we speak is voting on
whether to condemn the United States for
moving its embassy
Jerusalem which we should say eff off
who cares what you have to say why do I
possibly care what Venezuela where its
citizens are eating dogs have to say
about where we put our embassy why would
I care about the organization of Islamic
countries 57 Islamic countries who hate
Jews why would I possibly care what they
have to say about whether Jerusalem
should be Jewish territory why in the
world would I have to care about that
it's somehow we're supposed to care
about this we're supposed to care deeply
that the UN which is basically Mos
Eisley okay you will never find a more
wretched hive of scum and villainy than
the United Nations General Assembly I
hate the United Nations so much that
while I'm against the use of eminent
domain to hand over to private
businesses because I think that that's
illegal I would be willing to make an
exception of President Trump wanted to
use eminent domain to bulldoze the UN
and build a Trump Tower on top of it I'd
be fine with that in fact I think the
best use of the UN would be throw out
all the diplomats and use it as an
asylum housing project for all of the
people who have to run from the garbage
countries that occupy the UN the UN is
an awful institution it has done
literally nothing good since basically
inception except for voting for the
establishment of the State of Israel
name the good things the UN has done
I'll wait okay then the UN is a terrible
organization and it is a wildly
anti-semitic organization is it a shock
but they're trying to pass another
Assembly resolution against Israel is
that a shock let me explain to you why
this is not a particular shock I begin
with a few statistics so for all those
people like well you know the UN that
Center of moral gravitas when they come
after Israel that really means something
no it doesn't mean anything it is it
doesn't mean anything here are some
statistics for you how much does the
United Nations hate Israel there 193
countries in the UN more than a quarter
of them are Muslim countries who hate
Israel and then you haven't gotten
started with the Europeans okay Jews
ain't exactly popular in Europe as
demonstrated by Exhibit A the Holocaust
so things have not gone well for Jews in
Europe historically here's how the UN
has voted with regard to Israel a
country full of Jews okay UN Human
Rights Council which is supposed to be
there to you know probably get Human
Rights you might think that they would
have some resolutions against China for
being a repressive communist country
that forces abortions on its citizens or
maybe against North Korea a giant prison
state a giant gulag or maybe
against Venezuela an oil-rich petro
oligarchy that has been using its oil to
prop up its leadership while
simultaneously forcing its citizens to
shoot animals to eat in the streets you
might think that the UN Human Rights
Council might have some things to say
about that well now from its creation in
June 2006 through June 2016 a full
decade the UN Human Rights Council has
adopted 135 resolutions criticizing
countries this is thanks to UN watchdog
they've adopted 135 resolutions
criticizing countries 135 how many of
them were against Israel one country
6868 literally half of all UN
resolutions at the Human Rights Council
criticizing a country have been directed
not against North Korea not against Iran
not against Saudi Arabia not against
Egypt not against China not against
Venezuela against not against Cuba
against Israel the only time a kradic
free country in the Middle East half of
them
okay the UN General Assembly as I say
the the Star Wars Cantina of garbage of
human debris came from 2012 through 2015
the UN General Assembly has adopted 97
resolutions criticizing countries how
many of those were against Israel say we
have a wild guess I'm taking guesses
Jonathan how many of the new and UNG a
UN GA has it up to 97 resolutions
criticizing countries how many of those
have been against Israel specifically 83
of the 97 83 of 97 resolutions
criticizing any country are directed
against Israel how about the UA UNESCO
the UN Educational Scientific and
Cultural Organization they're there for
education and health they're there to
inform people did they have any
resolutions criticizing Hamas for
literally using UN schools as launching
pads for rockets during the Gaza war no
but they do have 10 resolutions a year
they adopt around 10 resolutions a year
how many of those resolutions have been
against Israel all of them literally all
there has been one one resolution
against another country and that was
against Syria in 2013
since then Syria has been great by the
way things have just been swimming in
Syria I mean UNESCO has had nothing to
say about Syria well five hundred
thousand Syrians were slaughtered but
Israel boy oh boy that Israel the World
Health Organization
they don't even adopt resolutions
against countries they adopt resolutions
against Israel literally they adopt one
resolution a year singling out Israel
for condemnation the International Labor
Organization was established to improve
conditions of labor regulate work hours
and fight unemployment and assure
adequate living wages Israel has the
strongest economy in the Middle East and
it ain't close and it's an annual
conference the ILO the Iowa only
produces one country specific report
guess the name of the country so is it
super shocking that the UN has decided
to single out Israel and say the
Jerusalem is not Jewish territory is it
super shocking that the Palestinian
Authority a terrorist group has come out
and said how dare the United States try
to blackmail us they're trying to
blackmail us they're trying to say that
if we oppose them they'll cut off aid
the United States okay
the Palestinians don't get to talk about
blackmail Palestinian Authority Hamas
Islamic Jihad their entire strategy is
if you don't give us what we want we
will come into our house and murder your
children and as extortion is their
entire political strategy and has been
for decades but they're ripping the
United States so as I said earlier nikki
Haley the UN Ambassador under President
Trump is my spirit animal President
Trump led off this UN thing by saying
himself listen if they want to if they
want to opposes that the UN will just
cut their funding take hundreds of
millions of dollars and even billions of
dollars and then they vote against us
well we're watching those votes let them
vote against us we'll save a lot we
don't care yes okay this is the Trump
who in 2011 I thought maybe be good
president this is okay this is not just
good Trump this is not just great Trump
this is exhilarating Trump okay this is
fantastic Trump the big fu to all these
countries who take our money and then
use it for terrorism ace is fine you
want to vote against this we'll just cut
off your money how's that hey like that
hey like dem apples
love it and then nikki Haley goes full
board Jean Kirkpatrick at the UN and it
is fantastic nikki Haley you can see the
you know I don't know whether to say
that I have Haley s courage or she has
Shapiro s courage but whatever it is we
have million we have mind merged here
nikki Haley is now mice at the UN not
nikki Haley all the time and nikki Haley
at the UN at the General Assembly this
is my
spirit animal right here United States
will remember this day in which it was
singled out for attack in the General
Assembly for the very act of exercising
our right as a sovereign nation we will
remember it when we are called upon to
once again make the world's largest
contribution to the United Nations and
we will remember it when so many
countries come calling on us as they so
often do to pay even more and to use our
influence for their benefit America will
put our embassy in Jerusalem that is
what the American people want us to do
and it is the right thing to do yes yes
okay this is this is correct why we even
spend a dime at this defunct pathetic
institution is beyond me you just
bulldoze the damn place and we should
make all these jackasses pay their
parking tickets you make all these all
these diplomats who've been out there
raping people they have diplomatic
immunity we should drag them into court
like enough of this nonsense
in the UN it's a garbage institution
it's been a garbage institution for
quite a while okay in a second I am
going to discuss the the Trump tax plan
and the fallout it's been a very good
week for Team Trump very good week for
Team Trump but first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at quip so if
you are at all concerned about your
health
then you should be concerned also about
your dental health because one thing
that we know is that dental health is
actually linked to things like heart
health and one thing that everybody does
wrong is brushing their teeth people
brush their teeth wrong you know that an
electric toothbrush does a lot more for
you than a manual toothbrush well quip
is the ultimate in electric toothbrushes
it's the new electric toothbrush that
packs just the right amounts of
vibration into an ultra slim design
guiding pulses to simplify better
brushing it's a fraction of the cost of
bulkier brushes it comes with a mountain
goes right on your mirror it also offers
an optional subscription plan so the new
brush heads will arrive on a dentist
recommended three months scheduled for
just five bucks including free shipping
worldwide that I think is a fantastic
idea because even if you buy an electric
toothbrush it's more expensive you don't
have to worry about when you go out and
you buy the new brush heads or when you
replace them if you get on the quick
schedule the new brush head arrives
exactly when it's supposed to you just
replace it and you don't have to think
about it anymore
quip is the ideal size and price to give
anyone on your holiday list on your
Christmas list you can even include the
automatic brush head deliveries for a
year so ensure your gift keeps on giving
until the next holiday its featured in
pretty much every gift guide its
featured in Forbes its featured in men's
health it's featured in even GQ it's
backed by a network of over 10,000
dental professionals including dentists
hygienists and dental students quip
starts at just 25 bucks and right now
when you go to get quip comm slash
Shapiro you get your first refill pack
free with a quip electric toothbrush so
that's your first free pill refill pack
free at get quip comm slash Shapiro get
quip comm slash Shapiro again it's just
25 bucks to start and you get your first
refill pack free GE t qu IP comm slash
your Pierrot make your dental health
better use that trip hero the slash
repair oh so they know that we sent you
okay so the Democrats have been
struggling ardently to figure out
exactly how to counter president Trump's
tax reform bill what exactly do they do
how exactly can they counter this and
they've been having a really rough time
of it because it turns out that the tax
bill actually gives a tax break to
pretty much everybody the tax bill is
going to be good for the economy that
it's not going to harm the economy the
real only point to push back on the tax
bill comes from some conservatives who
are deficit hawks like Kevin Williamson
who says listen at some point we're
gonna have to get our spending under
control that's true but that's not
really a critique of the tax cut so much
as it is a critique of our failure to
cut our spending right even if there
were no tax cut we'd have a massive debt
so we have to cut our spending in other
words anyway but the tax cut itself is
slated to help the economy and this is
what's scaring Democrats also the
polling numbers have apparently started
to turn around for the tax cut already
as people begin to see that this tax cut
is not some sort of boondoggle to help
the rich the Democrats are beginning to
panic they're starting to freak out so
it's led by folks like Seth Meyers South
Meyers of course the late-night host and
now we have to have all of the political
thoughts of our late-night house it's
just it's vital for me to hear what the
guy who used to write for Comedy Central
has to say a guy who used to write
comedy lines for President Obama has to
say about the tax cuts this seems like a
real honest broker to me here's Seth
Meyers saying that the GOP tax bill is a
brazen heist
brazen first of all I do love when
people use the word brazen but really
only one is followed by huh see I think
that brazen brazen hussy is is a great
historic film phrase but in any case
it's a brazen high
according to Seth Meyers here we go the
public has passed a sweeping overhaul of
the tax code that will overwhelmingly
benefit corporations in the wealthy
amounting to nothing less than a brazen
heist of the country okay if brazen
heist of the country who stole the
country is like where in the world is
Carmen Sandiego if you ever watched that
that show or played that game it would
be people stealing like actual monuments
there's like Carmen Sandiego just stole
the the Washington Monument where did
the country go if it was heisted why am
I still here where are we in a different
zone what's happened now first I was
killed and then they stole my country
it's so weird what what's going on why
does everything seem thing everything
seemed exactly the same
it was weird I woke up at 5:00 yeah I
woke up very early this morning and I
got in my car and I looked around I saw
there was no one on the roads and I
figured everyone had been killed by the
by the tax bill but as it turns out it
was just 5:30 in the morning and who the
hell is on the road at 5:30 in the
morning so that was the actual solution
because I got at nine o'clock everybody
was out doing their normal stuff in any
case the Democrats are struggling to
come up with the rationale for opposing
this thing so they've tried the Seth
Meyers it's a brazen heist
they have also tried the tax cuts just
don't do anything all right so we've
heard this from a couple of Democrats
saying well you know at the lower end of
these tax cuts some families are only
getting back like 80 dollars a month is
that really a lot of money is that
enough to do anything does that even
matter it matters to the person who's
getting back 80 bucks a month it's not
nothing
it's better than not having $80 a month
let's put it that way my favorite though
my favorite defense of opposition to the
tax cut comes courtesy of one of the
worst representatives in Congress I've
actually openly supported to his
opponent I generally don't support
politicians and races but I've openly
supported his opponent in California
this guy is Ted Lou Ted Lou is the is
the Congress person from now here's
somewhere in in the city in like LaBrea
area and and Ted Lou says that this bill
will harm Americans here is his initial
statement on it yesterday Democrats are
not opposed to tax reform we're opposed
to harmful tax reform and this bill is
going to harm America by exploding our
deficit by 1.5 trillion dollars it's
then gonna require automatic cuts of 25
billion of Medicare and most of the
benefits of this tax bill go to the
super wealthy okay so all of this is
happy talk then he got too
is real point his real point he made on
Twitter and it is demonstrative of how
some people on the left think about the
role of government and what it's
supposed to do here is what ted Lieu
tweeted quote GOP underestimates how
people feel when they know others got a
better deal if Sally gets a tax cut of
$380 but others get two hundred thousand
dollars she will be upset and wait until
Joe finds out he is getting a tax
increase for residing in California
that's why tax bill is so unpopular
human nature hmm
deep thoughts there from ted Lieu human
nature now here's the thing I agree with
Ted Lou I agree human nature is for us
to be jealous jerks that is our nature
our nature is to see the guy next door
at the lab ragini and think but if I
work harder maybe I too will have a lab
ragini which is totally acceptable but
that guy has a lab redeeming I'm gonna
go key it right or that guy has a
Lamborghini what if I stole it
hey debt is human nature right we are a
jealous crew we are not kind the
green-eyed monster of envy gets us all
this is why there is an explicit
commandment in the 10 that specifically
deals with this - shall not cover the
neighbors ask al franken that you shall
not covet your neighbor's property
that's the idea okay it's actually
breaking a commandment to fall in with
Ted Lou's logic here this is why we have
created institutions to prevent us from
acting out on our jealousy the founders
also believed that we were jealous and
that we wanted each other stuff and so
instead what they said is we will set up
a system where you can't take each
other's stuff there will be checks and
balances there will be people who can
vote against you there will be
institutional barriers to you being able
to do this ted Lieu apparently believes
that jealousy as a motivating factor
should decide policy right the jealousy
should decide policy now how does he get
from the is to the art how does he make
that jump from people are jealous - we
should humor their jealousy by stealing
some people's money and giving each
others how does he get from one to the
other the answer is of course the ted
Lieu believes like so many Democrats
believe that what you're jealous of is
actually not that guy's property what
you're jealous of is not jealousy it's
rage at the injustice of a cruel
universe that can be healed by an
overarching government power right
you're not jealous of that guy's
Lamborghini you're angry at the system
that allows a douche like that guy with
the lab ragini to have a lab redeeming
and it's the system that's response
your neighbor he's not responsible for
the lab ragini the system's responsible
so if we just changed the system you too
can have a lab Regina or even better no
one can have a lab Rajini ever and this
is the illogic air which coincidentally
violates at least two others of the ten
commandments right the commandment that
says you're not allowed to steal it
turns out that it is still theft if you
vote for somebody to go steal something
right if Austin and Malthus both come
into this room and they say we just held
a vote there are three of us here the
two of us vote to take half their salary
this would be theft okay I would also
fire them hey listen the visit this
would be that if the idea and is not
theft so long as you vote for the theft
is really stupid
so that violates another one of the Ten
Commandments then there's the third of
the Ten Commandments violates which is
the notion of in a supreme arbiter of
the universe a God who is just and good
right the idea that government can
replace God and that government can
provide to you all of the necessities
that you seek my dad is what Democrats
are basically saying that if a poor
person exists in a rich person exists
government can come in and heal all lows
so the Democrats are beginning to show
their hand and it's an ugly hand it
really is I mean this is ugly stuff that
you're hearing from the Democrats and
this is why you have people like Bernie
Sanders whose entire race on debt is
jealousy right everything Bernie Sanders
is about is the idea the income
inequality this talking point I said it
many many times I'll say it again that
income inequality is not an issue to me
so long as my life that's getting better
if it's an issue to you even though your
life is getting better it's because
you're a bad person really I think it's
that simple
if income inequality is an issue for you
if everyone's life is getting better but
income inequality is still an issue for
you it shows a moral shortcoming if you
think income inequality is bad because
it breaks social fabric or anything
income inequality is bad because it's a
zero-sum game I think you're wrong but
that's at least argue about if you just
think that income inequality is bad
because you're jealous or because you
think the system is is quote/unquote
rigged but you have no evidence the
system is rigged if you are if you're if
everyone's life is getting better but
you're angry that everyone's life is
getting better that everyone's life
level is going up
but the people at the bottom it's going
up this much and people the tops going
up this much if you're angry about that
that makes you a bad person because what
you should really be focused on is argue
rising or are you falling is the society
rising or is the society falling Bernie
Sanders of course works
zero-sum game philosophy of life in
which no one can rise without someone
else falling so you know somebody
apparently in in New Guinea had to pay
for Bernie Sanders ii lake house in any
case here is Bernie Sanders saying that
the fact is that we need the revenge
I would like Putin I will stand on the
barricades with my pudding I will stand
there with my vanilla pudding like that
is the flavor that I prefer after a year
of doing Bernie Sanders impressions I
can tell you vanilla pudding is my
flavor I love vanilla
I am lukewarm on chocolate and caramel
tastes like dog crap but the pudding I
enjoy is vanilla pudding I will stand
upon the barricades like the people in
lame is which is not coincidentally also
my favorite musical except for the guard
pots and I will tell you that we need
revenge revenge on Trump and I will lead
it I will use my Walker and I will walk
over to the White House and I will beat
him
with the tennis ball end of my Walker
Bernie Sanders go this whole policy is
based on the fraudulent theory of
trickle-down economics and that is if
you give huge tax breaks to large
corporations and the wealthy somehow the
middle class and working families
benefit problem is that theory has never
worked it didn't work on the Reagan it
didn't work on the george w bush they
didn't work recently in the state of
kansas ok so tax cuts do work and i will
explain why in just a second and i will
show you how the Democrats are making
complete fools of themselves but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at saucy so normally at this time I
talk about why you might want to get
drunk out of despair but now you might
just want to get drunk out of happiness
or you just might want to drink out of
happiness you might want to enjoy your
life a little bit more with some
excellent spirits and that is where your
friends at saucy come in it is the
alcohol delivery app they deliver your
favorite wine beer and liquor right to
your door on demand it is the lyft or
uber for alcohol my wife and I use this
the other day we were having a party yes
believe it or not despite my constant
refrain that we do not have friends we
actually do I know shocking surprise for
sending there but we actually had a
party in our house and we were running
out of alcohol so I dialed the Petoskey
up and boom they were at my door within
15 minutes with precisely the alcohol
that I
requested if you are in a big city like
LA San Francisco Chicago San Diego or
Sacramento they will come to your door
in less than 50 in less than 30 minutes
for the rest of us saucy delivers beer
wine and liquor tears or in two days or
less nationwide so if you are organizing
a party and you want to get the best
price on Mike her
go to saucy there are no minimum orders
no delivery fees no run into the store
if you have the saucy app you've got a
fully stocked bar right down on your
phone and for a limited time you get 15
bucks off when you download the saucy
app and you enter promo code Ben which
means you're getting some free alcohol
essentially for a limited time $15 off
when you download the saucy app and
enter promo code Ben saucy si you see ey
enter promo code Ben for 15 bucks off
again use that promo code Ben also so
that they know that we sent you saucy is
great you'll make your life more
enjoyable and there's a lot to celebrate
this holiday season okay so the
Democrats have been claiming without any
evidence to support it really that the
that somehow this is going to hurt the
middle class that corporations don't
actually spend the money on people that
somehow the corporations just sock it
away in their Scrooge McDuck money bins
and every evening they go swimming in
the coins the physics of that I always
found puzzling by the way I'm not sure
how Scrooge McDuck was actually able to
penetrate the metal over the coins he
was always able to sort of jump between
the coins but I get the feeling that if
you tried to jump into a pile of coins
you'd really hurt yourself in a severe
way in any case that's beside the point
the actual point that I didn't want to
make is that the Democrats are claiming
that this tax cut will be wildly
ineffective the corporations have no
intention of helping you they have no
intention of helping you at all and
leading the charge here is Chuck Schumer
so Chuck Schumer the the Senate Minority
Leader from New York here's what he had
to say about the tax rates know there's
great irony of this you're gonna hear
him rip one particular company here that
company is AT&T I'll explain why this is
so hilarious and ironic in one second
because he basically says something and
it gets debunked as he is saying it it's
pretty astonishing well if you believe
trickle-down economics he's right the
trouble is no one in America not the
American public know econo
not the economists believe that
trickle-down works corporations are
flush with cash right now
the stock market's booming job creation
isn't look at all the companies that
have already said they're going to use
their tax break
for stock buybacks for dividends that
don't affect average Americans and I
love the example of AT&T over the last
10 years AT&T has paid an average tax
rate of 8% a year they have 80,000 fewer
employees today than they had then tax
breaks don't lead to job creation they
lead to big CEO salaries and money for
the very very wealthy ok so here's the
part that's hilarious and ironic as he's
saying AT&T they didn't spend any money
on their employees they paid very little
taxes in their spending no money on
their employees first of all these sort
of reversing the polarity one of the
reasons corporations pay less in taxes
because they're making less money or
they've had realizable losses in the
last year right I mean it's not like
they can just pay less taxing it away
with it in any case what did AT&T do
Chuck Schumer speaking in the same hour
the same hour AT&T announced that once
president from signed the bill into law
they would quote invest an additional 1
billion dollars in the United States in
2018 and pay a special $1,000 bonus to
more than 200,000 AT&T US employees oops
oops pick the wrong company to pick on
that time Chucky and it's not just AT&T
saying this boeing has announced 300
million dollars of investment in
corporate giving and workforce
development in new facilities and
infrastructure Fifth Third Bank Corp is
a bank headquartered in Ohio they
announced they would give a minimum
hourly wage raise it all the way to 15
bucks you remember the left who's saying
they want a $15 minimum wage they got it
approved by President Trump how through
economic growth they're also gonna give
a one-time bonus of a thousand bucks to
more than 13,500 of their employees
Wells Fargo there's a lot more employees
than that announced they will increase
their minimum hourly pay rate to 15
bucks
and they will aim for 400 million
dollars in philanthropic donations next
year due to the newly passed GOP tax
bill Ryan Saavedra writes about the
silver daily wire Comcast has announced
they're gonna give thousand dollar
bonuses to over a hundred thousand
eligible frontline and non-executive
employees and invest 50 billion bucks
over the next five years in
infrastructure based on the passage of
tax reform Fed Ex announced that they
will ramp up hiring in response to the
bill
they say they're going to see a 1.3
billion dollar increase in annual profit
and they are promising extended hiring
CBS announced last month that they would
create three thousand permanent new jobs
if the tax bill passed so much for Chuck
Schumer's talking point that businesses
do not respond to economic incentives of
course they respond to economic
incentives of course they do
ok and as I discussed yesterday when
Ireland lowered its corporate tax rate
from 40 percent to 12.5 percent
they basically tripled their GDP growth
when businesses have more money to spend
they either invest it or they do stock
buybacks its wages stock prices or they
spend it on investment in employees and
innovation my dozens go nowhere as
opposed to when Democrats spend the
money when it legitimately goes almost
nowhere alright so this is this is good
stuff and I will say another thing here
about a differentiation that I think is
important so if you recall all the way
back to the show last it would have been
December so last December Oh a year ago
President Trump announced that he and
Mike Pence had basically cut a deal with
carrier to keep 500 jobs in the United
States with carrier and I said I didn't
like this deal the reason I didn't like
this deal is because it wasn't a
broad-based tax cut it was a special
giveaway to carrier it was basically a
subsidy to carrier
I don't like subsidies and so when
carrier said they keep the jobs there I
said this is a cheap trick it's a parlor
trick and I don't like it it looks a lot
like corporatism this is not that when
companies say a broad-based policy that
affects millions of people across the
United States is good for us or bad for
us that is necessary companies should be
doing that corporate heads should
routinely be speaking out about how
public affairs impacts their company why
because the government constantly does
and if you're Democrat you spend your
entire life going around telling people
you know this government program that I
love you love it too you know why
because it puts money in your pocket
right this is what Democrats do for a
living for a living Democrats go around
telling people that food stamps are
great and the way you know it is because
there's an EBT card in your pocket
welfare is great and the way you know it
is every day every week when you go to
pick up your welfare check it's a little
bit more because of me right the
Democrats are constantly letting people
know that they are dependent on
government programs capitalists don't
tend to spend a lot of time letting
people know that they are reliant on
capitalism I don't run around the office
telling people around the office guys
you know what you are reliant on me for
your hiring but not only
that your reliance on the capitalist
system your alliance on free-market
enterprise for your continuation of your
employment because that make me a jerk
like we're kind of polite we don't go
around saying these sorts of things but
they are true okay my employees will
have a better year because there were
corporate tax cuts maybe not in
California but overall there will be a
better year for us as a company because
of these corporate tax cuts the rate
just went from 35 percent to 21 percent
that's a massive decrease hey and people
should be telling their employees this
the reason they should be telling their
employees this is because otherwise the
Democrats have a stake in basically
suggesting that employees and employers
are on two sides of the ledger there
they're not related that you can damage
the employer without harming the
employee that's not true when you raise
taxes it harms the employee and when you
lower taxes it helps the employee and
this is what we've seen you know
president Trump deserves a moment in the
Sun to celebrate and thus he did so he
came out yesterday and he said hey it's
a lot of fun when you win can't argue
with that Paul Ryan and MIT she was a
little team we just got together and we
would work very hard didn't we huh it
seems like there was a lot of fun it's
always a lot of fun when you win
if you work hard and lose that's not
acceptable okay and I do love the the
rabbit laughter in the background from
the vice president and from all of the
all of the assembled now one of the
things that I think Republicans have
learned is sort of how to play with
Trump and the way that you play with
Trump is by basically laughing at all
his jokes and telling him he's the best
if that's what it takes to get some good
policy I can live with that does mu know
is it sycophantic is it ridiculous the
president is this way
yes but hey the policy over the last
three weeks has been pretty pretty
pretty good okay now in a second I'm
gonna explain something that Trump said
that is not true about this bill and
then I want to get back to some of the
Democratic reactions to all of this
because some of the Democratic reactions
are truly astonishing so let's start
with with something president Trump said
about Obamacare so when it comes to this
bill one of the things that the bill
does is it repeals the individual
mandate as I explained yesterday the
repeal of the individual mandate does
not mean Obamacare has been repealed it
has not you are not forced to by an
insurance program now but insurance
companies are still forced to cover
pre-existing conditions they're still
all sorts of costs the cost caps on what
insurance companies can do
there are still heavy regulations on
insurance companies across the country
which is one of the reasons why cutting
the insurance mandate the individual
mandate may result in higher prices in
the individual insurance market because
if you're forcing a bunch of healthy
people young healthy people to buy
insurance in order to cover the cost for
older non healthy people and then you
take all the young people out of the
system the costs rise for the insurance
companies there are only two ways of
filling that gap one is to remove the
regulations that would be killing
Obamacare it's killing the regulations
and the other way to do it would be to
backfill that gap by basically signing
subsidies to the insurance companies
with government cash unfortunately it
looks like the Republicans have sided
with the second way they're looking at
the Alexander Murray bill to do exactly
that maybe Lamar Alexander and patty
Murray of the state of Washington this
bipartisan bill but Trump made an
announcement that was somewhat
disquieting here and should I think give
people a little bit of pause going into
next year because this is been a great
last three weeks okay I've said it I
said it yesterday the last three weeks
last month of policy from this
administration has been the most
conservative policy of any policy I have
seen in my lifetime
now granted I don't remember the Reagan
years particularly but certainly in the
last 33 years I mean as long as I've
been alive this is the most this is the
most conservative policy that I've seen
in the last three weeks ever right much
more conservative than anything george w
bush did but going into next year the
question is are we gonna keep up this is
this where we're gonna go the indicators
are maybe not the reason i say this is
because here's President Trump talking
about the repeal of the individual
mandate and what comes next here he
explains the individual mandate is being
appealed when the individual mandate is
being repealed that means Obamacare is
being revealed because they get their
money from the individual mandate so the
individual mandate is being repealed so
in this bill not only do we have massive
tax cuts and tax reform we have
essentially repealed Obamacare and will
come up with something that will be much
better okay that's not true we have not
essentially repealed Obamacare we
repealed a funding mechanism for the
insurance companies but all the
regulations are still in place unless
the Republicans remove those regulations
then and then they are basically
a new government program I mean if they
basically are just gonna give giveaways
to sick people who can't afford
insurance and that is a new government
entitlement program the problem with
that is that you're not always talking
about sick old people those people are
covered by Medicare already you're
really talking about young people who
should have bought insurance and didn't
if you want incentives for people to buy
insurance then there has to be a
punishment right an incentive system is
based on reward and punishment
there has to be some sort of punishment
for not buying insurance when you could
have when you were younger if you just
pay for it then there's no incentive
it's a pathway to a government sponsored
program so I'm glad the individual
mandate is gone but it is not true that
Obamacare itself has been taken apart
now the same thing is true with regard
to daca you know Mitch McConnell is
smartly saying that the Republicans
should wait on pushing deferred action
for childhood arrivals this would be the
Obama executive amnesty that trump
revoked but then asked Congress to pass
again I guess the Republicans are gonna
put this off until next year one of the
reasons for that is that they don't want
to sort of blot the joy that so many
conservatives feel over Republicans
finally having a signature piece of
legislation McConnell says they might do
daca next year is daca on the senator
schumer and i've already discussed this
know will not be doing dark over but
this week that's what mattered to be
discussed next year the president's
given us to March to address that issue
we have plenty of time to do that
so the point here is that what we could
see next year is some programming that
we don't like so much in the last three
weeks it's all stuff I like we may see
next year daca we may see new subsidies
to insurance companies we may see this
giant infrastructure package that Trump
apparently still likes talking about
there are other priorities right there's
welfare reform that ones on the table
that would be a good one I'd like to see
president Trump pursue that he's talked
about adding more work requirements from
welfare this makes perfect sense to me
he's also talked about maybe
restructuring some forms of food stamps
in some ways again entitlement programs
need to be reformed the major reforms
that need to take place are really the
reforms that are happening in areas that
he's not going to touch Medicare
Medicaid Social Security that's the vast
majority of the American federal budget
that's the stuff no one is willing to
touch we'll see where the agenda goes
from here but I was talking with a
member of the Trump administration last
night no what I said is I'm really
hoping that this is the Trump
administration turning the corner if not
if there's just a hype
I'll celebrate the high point but you
know you sort of have to hold off the
full-scale celebration until you know
where things go next in terms of
everything's hunky-dory from here on in
particularly with the approval rating so
low I mean the fact is that trumps
approval lading is rating is still down
in the 30s not only has he not suffered
any severe crises as president the
economy is doing really well and he just
passed a tax reform package really his
approval rating should be about 53% and
the very least it should be in the mid
40s this is why I say you know mr.
president please just sign off for
Twitter
spend the next couple of weeks enjoying
yourself let the media fulminate over
this because the Democrats will raise
your approval rating for you the
Democrats will play your Hillary Clinton
right bra Donald Trump won because
Hillary Clinton was a garbage candidate
Republicans can win as long as Democrats
continue to be insane so speaking of
insane Nancy Pelosi has apparently been
digging into one of her grandchildren's
high school reading lists because every
reference she makes is now some sort of
literary reference but a bad literary
reference like a literary reference that
makes no sense at all so she made a
literary reference yesterday to Tiny Tim
from a Christmas carol because she can't
come up with an actual victim of the tax
bill since it's just people keeping
their money but she can come up with a
fictional reference and that fictional
reference comes courtesy of Charles
Dickens Serkan 1843 in London let me
just suggest to Nancy Pelosi if you have
to go all the way back to a fictional
child in London in 1843 to find a victim
of the tax bill you're not very good at
this
here is Nancy Pelosi those dentures are
slipping in a slidin explaining the Tiny
Tim will be unceremoniously sacrificed
to the gods of capital Simon has a rare
disease and end thurible palsy his
mother spoke of how their family watches
the Muppet version of a Christmas carol
and how Simon sees himself in Tiny Tim
another kind boy with braces on his legs
unfortunately this story as of today
does not have the same kind of happy
ending as a Christmas Carol but this
story is not over and like Tiny Tim
Simon is family now find their future in
danger because of the greed of those
with power Tiny Tim oh they're gonna
kill Tiny Tim by the way she's not the
only person making the Tiny Tim
reference jackie speier democrat from
california she is also
relying on the Tiny Tim reference I'm
just very confused I understand that all
these Democrats think that the Christmas
carol story is a Democrat story the
story is about private charity based on
religious observance and if you miss
that it's because you didn't read the
story okay it's because you're
illiterate as maybe some of these people
are a christmas story is about a private
guy giving charity after being shamed
into it on Christmas a day honoring the
birth of Jesus right if you're a
Democrat by the way in your and you're
citing Tiny Tim let me just suggest that
you probably lay off the abortion stuff
because Tiny Tim is a kid with
apparently some sort of genetic
condition living in poverty so that
would be like number one on your
abortion target list if Nancy Pelosi is
around in eighteen forty eighteen
eighteen thirty eight and Tiny Tim is in
his mommy's tummy and they know that
Tiny Tim is gonna have some sort of
condition and they're living in poverty
she tells mommy to get an abortion and
both cratchits to go into nude body
painting in France in any case here is
jackie speier in california again making
a tiny tim reference in the house we are
going to shakedown hardworking Americans
a 1.3 or 2.3 depending on how you count
a trillion dollar tax cut and at the
same time or in fact nine million kids
in this
country athletes and these nine million
kids aren't eligible for Medicaid and
their families can't afford the
affordable care act because they have to
pay a certain amount and the subsidized
amount doesn't cover the cost so they
are truly out okay she's just making
things up now okay the Congress is about
to pay for the Children's Health
Insurance Program the massive the vast
vast vast majority of people who are
going to be quote-unquote thrown off
their insurance are opting not to be on
insurance after the end of the
individual mandate again the Tiny Tim
references are just absurd I love when
she says this is the worst bill in the
history of Congress do you even 1850
Fugitive Slave Act bro I mean like it
really hey do you have how about how
about prohibition was that a really
solid one how about the alien Sedition
Act so we actually put a Congress person
in prison how about the the public act
that allowed FDR to establish Japanese
internment how about the Chinese
Exclusion Act which prevented Chinese
people from becoming American citizens
after immigrating to the United States
or the Indian Removal Act which set this
the road for the Trail of Tears or the
War Powers Resolution and it turns out
that Congress didn't a lot of super
duper crappy things this exaggeration is
not helping I do love the Nancy Pelosi
made a second literary reference which
she also botched
she said that the tax bill is quote a
Frankenstein and anybody who's familiar
with Frankenstein knows it was a
creation a monster that was created well
know again Frankenstein's the name of
the doctor the monster is not named
Frankenstein you and then she says
do you know the ending of Mary Shelley's
story the monster comes back to destroy
that's not the end of the story does she
know how to read okay the end of the
story is that the monster after dr.
Frankenstein's death runs into the
Arctic wilds right just runs off into
the ice that's what happens at the end
of the story so I mean if you gonna make
a literary reference at least get it
right Nancy Pelosi literary references
not not solid not solid at all but it
just shows the desperation of the
Democrats and attempting to and
attempting to push against a bill that
really is not only not gonna harm people
but it's gonna help an awful lot of
people by the way the pressor
just beside themselves over this and I
do have to I'd you have to thrill with
President Trump as he taunts the press
here here was a glorious moment
yesterday when the president taunted the
press about them needing prayer so
without a good ask Ben Carson you can
stay if you want it because you need the
prayer more than I do I think you may be
the only ones maybe a good solid prayer
and they'll be honest
okay I gotta love that because they have
been deeply dishonest this week they
have been deeply dishonest this week
well in a second I'm going to explain to
you oh well actually this is breaking
news so here's here's a little bit of
breaking news the breaking news that the
UN General Assembly voted a hundred and
twenty eight to nine to declare u.s.
recognition of Jerusalem as Israel's
capital null and void so breaking UN GA
votes against Israel so which I respond
breaking who gives a flying bleep who
cares breaking not me just stupid okay
so in just a second we're gonna do some
things I like and some things I hate and
we have some pretty good things I like
and things I hate today for you but
first you're gonna have to go over to
daily we're calm and become a subscriber
yes you I'm talking to you okay for
$9.99 a month you can get a subscription
to daily wear watch the rest of our show
on video and be part of the team you can
be part of our mailbag which we do
tomorrow you'll be part of Michael Moses
mailbag you may be part of Andrew
Clemons mailbag you can view all of our
magical content that we create and be
part of the Shapiro store when it
eventually debuts in 2037 it's actually
coming much sooner than that I think in
any case you get all of those things
plus when you get the annual
subscription these all make great
Christmas gifts by the way and I can
take Christmas gifts cuz kind of comes
over now so if you if you miss Konica
too late you're screwed but but for
Christmas it's great gift you can for an
annual subscription you get all of those
things plus the ever fantastic ever
glorious unsurpassed often imitated
never duplicated left dis tears hot or
cold tumblr the greatest in all beverage
vessels this will make your blood run
warm in the winter chill it's just it's
it's the best thing that ever was people
tweet about it people love it people
live it somebody tried to marry it
that's illegal in Massachusetts still
but not for long
if we have our way in any case you get
all of those things when you get the
annual subscription plus go over to
sound town SoundCloud iTunes Google Play
stitcher any place to place podcast and
subscribe download the podcast every day
also please subscribe to our YouTube
channel we
Christmas video coming out when's that
coming out Austin's we know is that
today or tomorrow we have a Christmas
video coming out suffice it to say it
will embarrass me but make you laugh
that's the that I think is a fair
statement is it not so check that out
over at our YouTube channel we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
all righty time for some things I like
and then some things that I hate so
let's begin with a couple of things I
like so we've been doing some old
westerns so yesterday we did gunfight at
the OK Corral which is one that I really
enjoy
today I'm gonna do the original True
Grit not the new True Grit can the
neutral grit is not my favorite movie it
I don't know when Jeff Bridges decided
that English was no longer his native
tongue but it's it's it's a it's a great
irritation to me the Jeff Bridges has
decided to speak like Eliza Doolittle
in my fair lady with a mouth full of
marbles because Jeff Bridges really is a
good actor in hell or high water he's
terrific I think the true grit remake is
nothing special I think the original
True Grit is a much better movie it has
a much better score and it has of course
the oscar-winning performance from the
late John Wayne in full John Wayne mode
it's pretty great so here is here is the
original True Grit
says Life magazine True Grit is good
enough for me it's good enough for you
and if it isn't good enough for some
movie company then the free enterprise
system is really going to help
they tell me you're a man with true grit
what do you want baby good boy to
wrinkle the paper it's pretty loose
because your makings are too dry
I'm looking for Tom Chaney
who's he he's a man that shot and killed
my father Frank Ross says the New York
Times as touching as it is irreverently
amusing Rooster Cogburn and I are going
after the murder Tom Chaney and also
features that movie features the leg
glen campbell who need the the singer
who cannot act his way out of a paper
bag but is charming enough in the park
and it is and any features also a great
turn by Robert Duvall Robert Duvall is
the villain in the movie and creepy and
interesting and it's it's a really good
movie the original True Grit and of
course it has some classic lines it has
the very famous that very famous duel
scene near the end where John Wayne is
across the field from the bad guys and
then they charge at each other it's just
it's a very good movie it's a very
enjoyable film ok other things I like
now a thing from modern Hollywood that I
like yes really
it's a thing ok so I've said that I like
a lot of things actually that Hollywood
has been producing lately and I watched
a couple of movies on the plane the
other day that I liked and so I had no
internet access which is as close to
hell for me as possible
but I watched a couple movies this one
is not one of them this is a trailer
that is coming out for a movie called
Chappaquiddick oh yes you know what's
coming this movie is actually about you
guessed it Ted Kennedy basically
murdering a woman
so the Chappaquiddick incident happened
in in 1969 July 18th 1969 so apparently
it only takes Hollywood 50 years to come
around to actually making a movie about
an obviously publicized event they took
six months for them to come around and
making a movie about Joe Wilson and
Valerie Plame a nothing of a story that
had made it for a crappy movie it takes
him 5 seconds to make a movie about
Sarah Palin but I think some 50 years 50
years to make a movie about a guy who
probably would have been president
except he left a woman at the bottom of
a river and then swam to a house went to
sleep woke up the next morning and oops
she's dead yeah its head turns out
that's what you happen when you leave a
woman at the bottom of a river and it
was obviously manslaughter at best
murder at worst in any case the new
movie is Chappaquiddick and here's a
little bit of the preview in dad once
said
tragedy has a way of defining people
gonna pull some people to like curl up
into a ball
oh my god what have I done
well mr. Kennedy goes to Kennedy's death
she asked of a man well the influence
but the hell happened teddy
it was an accident
I was driving story like this could
dominate the headlines for weeks she we
got a body that body holds a lot of
Secrets supposed to be the difference
between guilt and innocence so we need
to be in control of them there's not a
lot of senators that are charged with
manslaughter that go on to become
present ok this was basically the thing
that destroyed Teddy Kennedy's political
aspirations for president he nearly won
the nomination anyway in 1980 away from
Jimmy Carter which demonstrates the
moral standards of the Democratic Party
but finally Hollywood has decided that
it might be worthwhile making a movie
about the most corrupt family in
American history no not the Bush family
no not the Clinton family the most
corrupt family in American history by a
fairly long margin is the Kennedy family
the Kennedys were deeply corrupt the
Kennedys the Kennedy men were
particularly evil okay Teddy Kennedy you
leave him alone at the bottom of the
river you don't get to get away with the
I'm a good guy routine especially when
you then spend the next several years of
your career sexually assaulting and
abusing women which is apparently what
Ted Kennedy did for decades you know
into his late old age like there was a
there's a friend of mine who was working
in Washington DC and an old man was
hitting on her and shouldn't realize who
it was it was Teddy Kennedy she was like
17 at the time right so Teddy Kennedy
was a disgusting perv his entire life
just because he put his name on some
important legislation means nothing but
it's just it's it is astonishing that it
took Hollywood 50 years to come around
to the idea that the Kennedy family
might need a little bit of scrutiny okay
time for a couple of quick things I hate
so thing that I hate number one when Tom
Hanks says that he doesn't want his
movie the post screen at the Trump White
House first of all I don't know why in
the hell anyone at the Trump White House
would want to screen this monstrosity I
mean this movie looks awful this movie
where Tom Hanks looks at Meryl Streep
and he says you know they really doubt
that you can do this because you're a
woman she said oh thank you for telling
me Tom the smarm level is 1 million on a
scale of 1 to 10 oh my god The
Washington Post was nearly shut down
yeah say here here is Tom Hanks saying
that he wouldn't want this shown at the
White House because Trump is a dictator
he's a dictator don't you understand
he's a dictator and on the subject of
truth the actor confesses to Galloway
honestly that he would decline to screen
the film at the White House if President
Donald Trump asked him to Hanks explains
I
would not have been able to imagine that
we would be living in a country where
neo-nazis are doing torchlight parades
in Charlottesville and jokes about
Pocahontas are being made in front of
the Navajo code talkers he continues and
individually we have to decide when we
take to the ramp it's totally fake you
don't take to the ramp it is taken to
the ramparts to make a movie about
lionizing the press and then not going
to the White House you're a real real
hero activity Tom yeah way to way to go
again he's not even asked to go to the
White House it's not even like Trump was
asked him then he refused
he's just preemptively saying I wouldn't
go to the White House to to meet Trump I
wouldn't go to the White House to to
screen my movie yeah these people have
real high moral quality real high moral
standards all of them defending Bill
Clinton up to the last five minutes when
it became inconvenient to defend an
alleged rapist okay other things that I
hate so I mentioned did I mention the
cat person story yesterday on the air a
little bit so I talked a little bit
about this cat person story this short
story called cat person from The New
Yorker about this 20 year old woman who
has sex with a 34 year old guy and then
and then she regrets it and somehow
she's the victim that woman who wrote
that story is now going to receive a 1
million dollar advance a 1 million
dollar advance for writing a story about
awkward sex welcome to America where I
guess that you telling your story and
making yourself into a victim or
creating a fictional character who's a
victim not because they're victimized
but because they made bad decisions this
makes you very very wealthy I don't
think it says a lot of good things about
the country okay well we're going to
stop there for today
but we will be back here tomorrow with
the mailbag so if you are going to
become a member now is the time to do it
because you want your questions answered
I know you do and after tomorrow we are
on Christmas break right I don't have
any shows next week so tomorrow is the
last show of the year is the last show
of the year of a grand glorious year and
I won't say my thank-yous to you and to
staff yes I can be grateful when I so
choose to be I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex zingaro audio is mixed by
Mike or Mina hair and makeup is by Jess
while alvera the ben shapiro show is a
daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2017